first make a spicy paste by crushing  garlic in a pestle and mortar  along with paprika  sea salt  and olive oil  spoon the paste onto phillips of  mackerel a great inexpensive oily fish  that's really healthy and leave to  marinade  when ready to eat put the mackerel  fillets on a baking tray skin side up  season and roast in a hot oven  next make a tangy potato salad  for the dressing mix dijon mustard  white wine vinegar  olive oil  and saffron  [Music]  and whisk until blended  boil new potatoes in salted water  drain and lightly crush  [Music]  add sliced spring onion and spoon in the  vinaigrette  [Applause]  to serve top the potato salad with the  roasted mackerel and drizzle with more  vinaigrette  [Music]  [Applause]  a healthy meal that makes the most of  cheap but delicious fish stunning  roasted mackerel with garlic and paprika  as it's cooking just tilt the pan  and bake  a few simple cuts through the rind means  the chop stays flat and cooks evenly